[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
she really should know about don't he
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let us also pray for all who mourn that
they may cast their care
pity upon the sorrows
[Music]
God and mercy nourish them with patience
comfort them
lift up
and give them peace through Jesus Christ
our Lord amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I am resurrection and I am life says the
Lord even though he died
and everyone who has life and has
committed himself to me in faith shall
not die forever as for me I know that my
redeemer lives and that at the last he
will stand upon the earth after my
awaking he will raise me up and in my
body I shall see God I myself shall see
and behold him who is my friend and not
a stranger for none of us has life in
himself and none becomes his own master
when he dies for if we have life we are
alive in the Lord and if we die we die
in the Lord
so then whether we live or die we are
the Lord's possession happy from now on
are those who die in the Lord so it is
says the spirit for they rest from their
labors
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please be seated
good morning my name is Randy Hollerith
I am Dean of Washington National
Cathedral on behalf of Mary Anne buddy
the Episcopal bishop of the diocese of
Washington and all of us who serve our
Lord at this Cathedral welcome welcome
to this house of prayer for all people
it is an honor to host this service for
Senator McCain to Senator McCain's wife
Cindy and his mother Roberta and the
entire McCain family our hearts are with
you and with all those across our
country and around the world who grieve
the loss of this great American patriot
and statesman today we give John Sydney
McCain the third back to the God of love
who gave him to us while we mourn his
death our faith tells us that beyond
this life there is indeed more life and
God never lets us go so as the old
prayer says we gather to give thanks for
all the goodness and courage that have
passed from John McCain's life into the
lives of others and have left the world
a richer and better place for his life's
task faithfully and honorably discharged
for good humor gracious affection kindly
generosity for sadness met without
surrender and weakness endured without
defeat may the Lord bless him and keep
him this day and always thank you
the world is a fine place and worth the
fighting for and I hate very much to
leave it when Ernest Hemingway's Robert
Jordan at the close for Whom the Bell
Tolls lies wounded and waiting for his
last fight these are among his final
thoughts
my father had every reason to think the
world was an awful place
my father had every reason to think the
world was not worth fighting for
my father had every reason to think the
world was worth leaving he did not think
any of those things like the hero of his
favorite book John McCain took the
opposite view you had to have a lot of
luck to have had such a good life I am
here before you today saying the words I
have never wanted to say giving this
speech I have never wanted to give
feeling the loss they have never wanted
to feel my father is gone John Sidney
McCain the third was many things he was
a sailor he was an aviator he was a
husband he was a warrior he was a
prisoner he was a hero he was a
congressman he was a senator he was a
nominee for president of the United
States these are all the titles and the
roles of a life that has been well lived
they are not the greatest of his titles
nor the most important of his roles he
was a great man we gather here to mourn
the passing of American greatness the
real thing not cheap rhetoric from men
who will never come near the sacrifice
he gave so willingly nor the
opportunistic appropriation of those who
live lives of comfort and privilege
while he suffered and served he was a
great fire who burned bright in a past
few days my family and I have heard from
so many of those Americans who stood in
the warmth and light of his fire
found it illuminated what is best about
them we are grateful to them because
they are grateful to him if you have
resented that fire for that light it
cast upon them for the truth it revealed
about their character but my father
never cared what they thought and even
that small numbers still had the
opportunity as long as they draw breath
to live up to the example of John McCain
my father was a great man he was a great
warrior he was a great American I
admired him for all of these things but
I loved him because he was a great
father my father knew what it was like
to grow up in the shadow of greatness he
did just as his father had done before
him he was the son of a great Admiral
who was also the son of a great Admiral
and when it came time for the third John
City McCain to become a man he had no
choice but in his own eyes walk in those
exact same has he had to become a sailor
he had to go to war he had to have his
shot at becoming a great Admiral as they
also had done the pass of his father and
grandfather led my father directly to
the harrowing hull of the Hanoi Hilton
this is the public legend that is John
McCain this is where all the biographies
the campaign literature and public
remembrances say he showed his character
his patriotism his faith and his
endurance in the worst of possible
circumstances this is where we learned
who John McCain truly was and all of
that is very true except for the last
part today I want to share with you
where I found out what John McCain truly
was it wasn't in the Hanoi Hilton it
wasn't in the cockpit of a fast and
lethal fighter jet it wasn't on the high
seas or on the campaign trail John
McCain was in all of those places but
the best of him was somewhere else
the best of John McCain the greatest of
his titles and the most important
of his roles was as a father imagine the
warrior the knight of the skies gently
carrying his little girl to bed
imagine the dashing aviator who took his
aircraft hurtling off pitching decks in
the South China Seas kissing the hurt
when I fell in skinned my knee
imagine the distinguished statesman who
counseled presidents and the powerful
singing with his little girl in oak
creek during a rainstorm - singing in
the rain
imagine the senator the fierce
conscience of the nation's best self
taking his 14 year old daughter out of
school because he believed that I would
learn more about America at the town
halls he held across the country
imagine the elderly veteran of Warren
government whose wisdom and courage were
sought by the most distinguished men of
our time with his eyes shining with
happiness as he gave his blessing for
his grown daughter's marriage you all
have to imagine that I don't have to
because I lived it all I know who he was
I know what to find him I got to see it
every single day of my blessed life John
McCain was not defined by prison by the
Navy by the Senate by the Republican
Party or by any single one of the deeds
in his absolutely extraordinary life
John McCain was defined by love several
of you out there in the pews who crossed
swords with him or found yourselves on
the receiving end of his famous temper
or were at a cross purposes to him on
nearly anything or right at this moment
doing your best to stay stone-faced
don't you know full well that if John
McCain were in your shoes here today
he'd be using some salty word he learned
in the Navy while my mother jabbed him
in the arm and embarrassment he looked
back at her and grumble and maybe stock
stop talking but he would keep grinning
she was the only one who could do that
on their first date
when he still did not know what sort of
woman she was he recited a Robert
service poem to her called the cremation
of
McGhee about an alaskan prospector who
welcomes his cremation as the only way
to get warm in the icy north there are
strange things done in the Midnight Sun
by the men who moil for gold the Arctic
trails have their secret tales that
would make your blood run cold he had
learned it in Hawaii a prisoner in the
next cell had wrapped it out in code
over and over again during the long
years of captivity my father figure that
if cindy-lou hensley would sit through
that and appreciate the dark humor that
had seen him through so many years of
cool imprisonment she just might sit
through a lifetime with him as well and
she did John McCain was defined by love
this love of my father for my mother was
the most fierce and lasting of them all
mom let me tell you what love meant to
John McCain and to me his love was the
love of a father who mentors as much as
he comforts he was endlessly present for
us and though we did not always
understand it
he was always teaching he didn't expect
us to be like him his ambitions for us
unmoored from any world the achievement
was to be better than him armed with his
wisdom and informed by his experiences
long before we were even old enough to
have assembled our own as a girl I did
not fully appreciate what I most fully
appreciate now how he suffered and how
he bore it with his stoic silence that
was once the mark of an American man I
came to appreciate it first when he
demanded it of me I was a small girl
thrown from a horse and crying from a
busted collarbone my dad picked me up he
took me to the doctor and he got me all
fixed up then he immediately took me
back home and made me get back on that
very same horse I was furious at him as
a child but how I loved him for it now
my father knew pain and suffering with
an intimacy and immediacy that most of
us are blessed never to have endure
he was shot down he was crippled he was
beaten he was starved he was tortured
and he was humiliated that pain never
left him the cruelty of his communist
captors ensured that he would never
raise his hoar arms above his head for
the rest of his life yet he survived yet
he endured yet he triumphed and there
was this man who had been through all
that with a little girl who simply
didn't want to get back on her horse he
could have sat me down and told me all
of that and made me feel small because
my complaint and my fear was nothing
next to his pain and memory instead he
made me feel loved Megan he said in his
quiet voice that spoke with authority
and men you had best obey get back on
the horse it did because I was a little
girl I resented it now that I am a woman
I look back across that time and see the
expression on his face when I climb back
up and rode again and I see the pride
and love in his eyes as he said nothing
is going to break you the rest of my
life whenever I fall down I'd get back
up whenever I am hurt I Drive on
whenever I am brought low I rise that is
not because I am uniquely virtuous or
strong or resilient it is simply because
my father John McCain was when my father
God's sake did I asked him what he
wanted me to do with this eulogy he said
show them how tough you are that is what
love meant to John McCain love for my
father also meant caring for the nation
entrusted to him my father the true son
of his father and grandfather was born
into an enduring sense of the hard-won
character of American greatness and was
convinced at the need to
send it with ferocity and faith John
McCain was born in a distant and now
vanquished outpost of American power and
he understood America as a sacred trust
he understood our public demands
responsibilities even before it defends
its rights
he knew navigating the line between good
and evil was often difficult but always
simple he grasped that our purpose and
our meaning was rooted in a missionaries
responsibility stretching back centuries
just as the first Americans looked upon
a new world full of potential for a
grand experiment in freedom and
self-government so their descendants
have a responsibility to defend the old
world from its worst self the America of
John McCain is the America of the
revolution fighters with no stomach for
the summer soldier and the sunshine
patriot making the world anew with the
bells of Liberty the America of John
McCain is the America of Abraham Lincoln
fulfilling the promise of the
Declaration of Independence that all men
are created equal and suffering greatly
to see it through the America of John
McCain is the America of the boys who
rushed the colors in every war across
three centuries knowing that in them is
the life of the Republic and
particularly those by their daring as
Ronald Reagan said gave up their chance
of being husbands and fathers and
grandfathers and gave up their chance to
be revered old men the America of John
McCain is yes the America of Vietnam
fighting the fight even in the most
forlorn cause even in the most grim
circumstances even in the most distant
and hostile corner of the world standing
even defeat for the life and liberty of
other peoples in other lands the America
of John McCain is generous and welcoming
and bold she is resourceful and
confident and secure she meets her
responsibilities she speaks quietly
because she is strong America does not
both because she has no need to the
America of John McCain has no need to be
made
again because America was always great
[Music]
[Applause]
that fervent faith that proven devotion
that abiding love that is what drove my
father from the fiery skies above the
Red River Delta
to the brink of the presidency itself
love to find my father as a young man he
wondered if he would measure up to his
distinguished lineage I miss him so
badly I want to tell him that he did but
I take small comfort in this somewhere
in the great beyond where the Warriors
go there are two Admirals of the United
States meeting their much-loved son
they are telling him he is the greatest
among them dad I love you I always have
all that I am all that I hope all that I
dream is grounded in what you taught me
you loved me and you showed me what love
must be an ancient Greek historian wrote
that the image of great men is woven
into the stuff of other men's lives -
had your greatness is woven into my life
it is woven into my mother's life it is
woven into my sister's life and it is
woven into my brother's lives it is
woven into the lit life and liberty of
the country you sacrificed so much to
defend dad I know you were not perfect
we live in an era where we knock down
old American heroes for all their
imperfections when no leader wants to
admit to fault or failure you were an
exception and you gave us an ideal to
strive for look I know you can see this
gathering here in this Cathedral the
nation is here to remember you like so
many other heroes you leave us draped in
the flag you loved you defended it you
sacrificed it you have always honored it
it is good to remember but we are
Americans
we don't put our heroes on pedestals
just to remember them we raise them up
because we want to emulate their virtues
this is how we honor them and this is
how we will honor you my father is gone
my father is gone and my sorrow is
immense but I know his life and I know
it was great because it was good and as
much as I hate to see him go I do know
how it ended I know on the afternoon of
August 25th in front of Oak Creek in
Cornville Arizona surrounded by the
family he loved so much
an old man shook off the scars of battle
one last time and a rose a new man to
pilot one last flight up and up and up
busting clouds left and right straight
on through to the kingdom of heaven and
he slipped the earthly bonds put out his
hand and touched the face of God I love
you dad
[Music]
[Applause]
from Requiem by Robert Louis Stevenson
under the wide and starry sky dig the
grave and let me Y glad we did I live
and gladly die and I laid me down with
the will be this the verse you grave for
me here he lies where he longed to be
home is the Sailor home from the sea and
the hunter home from the hill
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Cindy McCain and a wonderful McCain
family presidents Clinton Bush and Obama
secretaries Kissinger and Clinton all
the other honored guests that are here
ladies and gentlemen becoming John
McCain's friend is one of the great
blessings of my life
being asked to pay tribute to him today
is one of the great honors and for that
I thank Cindy and the entire McCain
family and I also want to thank them
including his mother his brother his
sister the seven wonderful children for
the love and support you gave John
throughout his life and his service none
more than in the last year of his life
and you Cindy have been absolutely thank
you have been absolutely saintly and we
his friends cannot thank you enough
there's a special satisfaction that
comes from serving a cause greater than
yourself I heard John say those words
hundreds of times particularly to young
people and you all heard them a lot as
well but for him we know they were not
just words in a speech they were the
creed that he lived by and the greater
cause to which he devoted his life was
America not so much the country defined
by its borders but the America of our
founding values freedom human rights
opportunity democracy and equal justice
under law in John's life he nobly served
and advanced these American values and
remarkably his death seems to have
reminded the American people that these
values are what makes us a great nation
not the tribal partisanship and personal
attack politics that have recently
characterized our life this week
celebration of the life and values and
patriotism of this hero I think you've
taken our country above all that in a
way it's the last great gift that John
McCain gave America and I want to
suggest today that we can give a last
great gift to him which is to nurture
these values and take them forward into
the years ahead to make America the
better country John always knew it could
be I pray that we will and I ask you to
do so as well now let me try to pay
tribute to this great man by describing
and sharing stories from our friendship
which began in the early 1990s as part
of a bipartisan group pushing our
government to stop the aggression and
slaughter in Bosnia and then we began to
collaborate on a lot of bipartisan
legislation but really our friendship
deepened in our travels together around
the world with our third amigo
Lindsey Graham when you traveled with
John even with Lindsey along the purpose
was not to have fun
in fact sometime it seemed the purpose
was just to survive the schedule he had
organized John had a restless energy
every day including the days we traveled
to get the most out of every day he
possibly could and he did and so did we
who were privileged to know him John
travelled to learn so he could be a
better senator he traveled to represent
America as
he could wherever we went and he did and
he travelled to support the men and
women of our armed services whether in
war or at peace wherever they were and
they in turn welcomed him in not just
respect but aw as the hero John McCain
was is and always will be in shared
experiences and long conversations on
these trips John and I got to know and
trust each other as friends in a way
that doesn't happen because it can't
happen much anymore in the frenetic
Washington Life of Senators our
friendship taught me many things
including I must add some jokes that I
otherwise never would have known John
loved to laugh and make others laugh
when he found a joke that people liked
he told it over and over and over again
one of my favorites was about the two
inmates going through the food line for
dinner at the State Penitentiary one
says to the other the food is terrible
here
and the other says it was a lot better
when I was governor
yeah I heard that one often and I
laughed every time because John laughed
so hard every time he told it the range
of John's mind interests and experience
was impressive and often surprising you
couldn't characterize this man he loved
to read history and fiction and talk
about it argue about it he had a
pervasive curiosity about just about
everything in life he loved the outdoors
in all of God's creatures large and
small who lived there most people would
be surprised by how much pleasure this
combative senator got from watching the
hummingbirds at the McCain family home
outside Sedona Arizona
but of course John's great strength was
his character he was honest fair and
civilized in all the times we were
together I never heard him say a bigoted
word about anyone the American people
saw this great quality most clearly
during the 2000 campaign when that woman
made her an offensive statement against
then-senator Barack Obama to me what was
most impressive about John's reaction
was that it was pure reflex it was who
John was he didn't need a consult anyone
he immediately defended his opponents
name and honor and thereby elevated for
that moment our politics and and made us
a more perfect union personally I could
tell you that John was a real friend in
accommodating what to him were my
unusual practices as a religiously
observant Jew whether it was walking
with me on a Saturday to an important
meeting or turning down a popular Freddy
night dinner invitation at the Munich
security conference we went to every
year because it was too far to walk we
would stay in the hotel and have what
John learned to call our Shalom Shabbat
dinners peaceful Sabbath dinners but of
course with John they weren't that
peaceful John naturally in doing these
wonderful acts of friendship grumbled
all the way about what I was putting him
through you know right now I think he's
probably deriving some pleasure from the
fact that it turned out that his funeral
was held on a Saturday and I had a walk
to get here I'm sure he if he were right
now he'd tell me that that was divine
justice he ultimately as he did with so
much of his life turned these interfaith
experiences into a truly hilarious
comedy routine it began with a solemn
pronouncement by John that he was
converting to Judaism then he explained
much less solemnly I do this not because
of any particularly liking for the
religion it's just that for so many
years I've had to go along with all of
Joe's religious nonsense that I might as
well convert and get the benefits one of
his favorite targets was the Sabbath
elevators in Israeli hotels which are
pre-programmed to stop at every floor
you know John had many virtues but
patience was not one of them
therefore rides on those shabad
elevators were not the happiest times we
spent and together
I say this both to say in stories how
full in genuine was John's acceptance of
my religious practices which were
different from what he knew but also to
make a larger point because I can tell
you when everything we did together
around the world and here in Washington
and across America
he showed that same acceptance respect
curiosity about everybody's religious
observances and about everything else
about them that was different from
himself and his own experiences I've
said that patience was one virtue of
John didn't have forgiveness was a great
virtue he did have and here's a story to
make that clear once on a trip to Hanoi
as we were touring the Hanoi Hilton the
crowd of Vietnamese college students
recognized John and they began to chant
wildly Mac Kayne Mac came they want her
to take his pictures and have him sign
autographs when it was over I asked him
why he got such a Rockstar reception in
Hanoi and with classic directness he
said well first charge because they've
been taught that I was treated a lot
better here than I really was and second
it's because of the normalization of
relations between the US and Vietnam
well that was a classic McCain
understatement
along with President Clinton and John
Kerry John McCain was the leader in
Congress in bringing about the
normalization of relations between the
u.s. and Vietnam an extraordinary act of
personal for
eveness when you consider what the
vietnamese did to him during his five
and a half years as a prisoner of war
after his injuries in vietnam he could
not pursue his ambitions in the Navy so
he turned to government service as his
greater American cause of course I
didn't know John and his youth but I
don't think from what I've heard that he
was born with the natural skills of a
legislator and yet he learned them and
became a great one he knew when to be
irascible and immovable and went to
negotiate and compromise to get
something done he regularly reached
across party lines because he knew that
was the only way to solve problems and
seize opportunities for the people of
our country in his state as a result his
legislative record is extremely
impressive he also fought and lost some
big battles to stop climate change to
close the gun show loophole to broadly
reform our immigration laws but that
never seemed to get him down or diminish
his ardour for the next battle he loved
to win but he also loved the good fight
for a just cause even if it didn't
succeed overall he won many more than he
lost and all of his big wins were
achieved with bipartisan support in 2008
when John was the Republican nominee for
president he had this far-out idea of
asking a Democrat to be his running mate
can you believe that let me explain it
to you as he did when he first talked to
me about it I said you know John I'm
really honored but I don't see how you
can do it even though I won my last
election as an independent I'm still a
registered Democrat John's response was
direct
and really ennobling that's the point
Joe he said with a certain impatience
you're a Democrat I'm a Republican we
could give our country the bipartisan
leadership it needs for a change when
John returned to the Senate after a
surgery last summer and voted against
the Republican health care bill some
people accused him of being disloyal to
his party and the president but that was
not the case if you listen to the speech
he gave that day you'll know it was not
the case that speech made clear that his
vote was not really against that bill
but against the mindless partisanship
that has taken control of both of our
political parties and our government and
produced totally one-sided responses to
complicated national problems like
health care and of course he was right
in his remarks last July John also spoke
eloquently of our position in the world
of America's continuing responsibility
for principled leadership in the world
It was as if he thought that might be
one of his last best opportunities to
move his colleagues in his country it's
a speech worth reading but I just want
to quote one sentence what greater cause
could we hope to serve than helping keep
America the strong aspiring
inspirational beacon of liberty and
dignity and defender of the dignity of
all human beings that in short was the
McCain American foreign policy moral
engaged and strong and again these words
were not just rhetoric for John he acted
on them he lived them in our travels
around the world I can tell you he
always reassured our allies and
unsettled or
he's standing for America's best values
attacking totalitarian governments
whether in Moscow to Iran Pyongyang or
anywhere else if we were going to a
country that was not fully free John
insisted that we meet with the local
human rights activists as well as the
government I will never forget that day
in Myanmar during the military
dictatorship there we met three men who
had just been released from political
prison and showed terrible signs of
physical and psychological abuse and yet
they told us that they would never have
survived if they had not heard in jail
that the great American Senator John
McCain had supported their cause read
their names on the US Senate floor and
demanded their release on another
occasion we visited a refugee camp for a
Syrians who had been forced out of their
country into Turkey by the brutal
aggression of Assad the Iranians and the
Russians we were the first members of
Congress to visit that campaign there
was some concern about the reception we
would receive earlier in the day in fact
that official of the UN had been there
and was booed and had shoes thrown at
him when we arrived a large crowd of
Syrian refugees had formed and was in
fact chanting but rather than booing and
throwing shoes they were cheering and
cheering cheering and chanting words of
welcome and thanks and the to words they
chanted most where John McCain what is
most remarkable about these two stories
and I could tell you many more is how
unremarkable they are
and that's because the name John McCain
based on the actions of the man John
McCain had become a source of hope and
inspiration for oppressed people
throughout the world as it was a source
of security for Allied countries that
share our values one last story one of
John's favorite cities in the world was
Jerusalem and one of his favorite things
to do there was to stand on the balcony
with Lindsay and me of our hotel looking
out at the old city and discussing all
the religious and political history that
had happened there over the centuries so
when I first told John that I had
decided not to run for the Senate again
in 2012 he was puzzled and frankly even
a little bit angry but then the next day
he called me and this is my best
recollection of the conversation he said
you know I've been thinking if you go
out into the private sector you're gonna
make some more money and then you and
Hadassah can afford to buy a second home
in Jerusalem that has an extra room for
me with a balcony where we could look
out and talk about that city and its
history well since then when I talked to
John or visited with him he would ask me
Joey
have you made enough money yet to buy
that place in Jerusalem
and I've answered not yet Johnny but I'm
getting closer now sadly fate has
intervened before we could realize that
dream but I am comforted by the fact
that Jerusalem is not just a holy and
historic city it is also the visionary
symbol of the dreams that all people
share and the destiny that we all desire
it is the original heavenly shining city
on the hill in that sense for many
people in the life of the spirit
Jerusalem the shining city on the hill
are really heaven and it is to that
heavenly Jerusalem where I am confident
the soul of John Sidney McCain the third
is going now and I want to imagine that
there's going to be a beautiful home
waiting for him there with a balcony
from which he can contemplate the
shining city and hopefully inspire us
here on earth to conduct ourselves with
just some of the patriotism principles
and courage that characterized his
magnificent life of service to America
and to so many noble causes greater than
himself
Godspeed dear friend may angels sing you
to your eternal home
[Applause]
our country has had the good fortune
that at times of national trial a few
great personalities have emerged to
remind us of our essential unity and
inspire us to fulfill our sustaining
values John McCain was one of those
gifts of destiny
I met John for the first time in April
1973 and a White House reception for
prisoners returned from captivity in
Vietnam he had been much on my mind
during the negotiations to end the
Vietnam War partly also because his
father then commander-in-chief of the
Pacific Command when briefing the
president answered references to his son
by saying only I pray for him in the
McCain's family national service was its
own reward they did not allow for
special treatment I thought of that
when it's Vietnamese captives during the
final phase of negotiations offered to
release John so that he could return
with me on the official plane that had
brought me to a noise against all my
instincts I thanked him for the offer
but refused it
I wondered what John would say when we
finally met excreting most close
self-effacing and moving thank you for
saving my honour he did not tell me then
or ever that he had had an opportunity
to be freed years earlier but had
refused a decision for which he had to
endure additional periods of isolation
and hardship no did he ever speak of his
captivity again during the near
half-century of close friendship chants
focus was on creating a better future as
a senator he supported the restoration
of relations with Vietnam helped bring
it about on a bipartisan basis in the
Clinton administration and became one of
the advocates of reconciliation with his
erstwhile
enemy Ana was draw chance Lord stir it
is an intangible quality it is not
obligatory it has no written code it
reflects an inward compulsion free of
self-interest it fulfills a cause not a
personal ambition it represents what a
society lives for beyond the necessities
of the moment law makes life possible
Ana and Noble said for John it was a way
of life John returned to an America
divided over its presidency divided over
the world amidst all the turmoil and
civic unrests divided over the best way
to protect our country and over whether
it should be respected for its power or
its ideals John came back from the war
and declared that this is a false choice
America ordered to itself to embrace
both strengths and ideals in decades of
congressional service ultimately as
chairman of the Senate Armed Services
Committee
John was an indefatigable exponent of an
America strong enough to vindicate its
Purvis but believed also in a
compassionate America governed by guided
by core principles for which American
foreign policy must always stand with
liberty and justice fall is not an empty
sentiment he argued it is the foundation
of our national consciousness - Jung
American marriages had universal
applicability I do not believe he said
that there is an Arab exception anymore
and there is a black exception Oh an
Asian or Latin exception he warned
against the temptation of withdrawal
from the world we will not rise in the
world
he warned there are leadership and
ideals our accent we would not deserve
it in this manner John McCain's name
became synonymous with an America that
reached out to oblige the powerful to be
loved and give hope to the oppressed
John were never academic Maxim's he was
in the frontlines of all these battles
for decency and freedom
he was an engaged warrior fighting for
his causes with a bullion miscarriage
and with humility to the limit of the
feasible and sometimes miraculously even
beyond it John was all about Oh in a
commencement speech at Ohio Wesleyan
University John summed up the essence of
his engagement of a lifetime no one of
us if they have character leaves behind
a wasted life like
like most people of my age I feel a
longing for what it's lost and cannot be
let's do it
but if the happy pursuits and natural
beauty of youth prove the femur
something better
cannon do it and then do it until our
last moments on earth and that is the
uneven and the lovely camp at the moment
in our lives when we sacrifice for
something greater than ourselves
heroes inspire us by the
matter-of-factness of their sacrifice
and the elevation of their vision the
world will be lonelier without charm
again it's a boolean his faith in
America and his instinctive sense of
moral duty none of us will ever forget
how eaten in his parting John has
bestowed on us a much needed moment of
unity and a renewed faith in the
possibilities of America
henceforth the country's honor is ours
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Cynthia the McCain family I am honored
to be with you to offer my sympathies in
to celebrate a great life
the nation joins your extraordinary
family and grief and gratitude for John
McCain some lives are so vivid it's
difficult to imagine them ended some
voices are so vibrant and distinctive
it's hard to think of them stilled a man
who seldom rested is laid to rest and
his absence is tangible like the silence
after a mighty roar thing about John's
life was the amazing sweep of it from a
tiny prison cell in Vietnam to the floor
of the United States Senate from
troublemaking plebe to presidential
candidate wherever John passed
throughout the world people immediately
knew there was a leader in their midst
and one epic life was written the
courage and greatness of our country for
john of me there was a personal journey
our hard-fought political history back
in the day he could frustrate me
and I know he'd say the same thing about
me but he also made me better in recent
years we sometimes talk of that intense
period like football players remembering
a big game in the process rivalry melted
away in the end I got to enjoy one of
life's great gifts the friendship of
John McCain and I'll miss it moments
before my last debate ever with Senator
John Kerry in Phoenix I was trying to
gather some thoughts in the holding room
I felt a presence opened my eyes and six
inches from my face was McCain who
yelled relax relax
john was above all a man with a code he
lived by a set of public virtues that
brought strength and purpose to his life
and to his country he was courageous
with the Kurds that frightened his
captors and inspired his countrymen he
was honest no matter whom it offended
presidents were not spared
he was honorable always recognizing that
his opponents were still Patriots and
human beings he loved freedom with the
passion of a man who knew its absence he
respected the dignity inherent in every
life a dignity that does not stop at
borders and cannot be erased by
dictators perhaps above all John
detested the abuse of power could not
abide bigots and swaggering despots
there was something deep inside him that
made him stand up for the little guy to
speak for forgotten people in forgotten
places when friend from his Naval
Academy days recalls how John while a
lowly plebe reacted to seeing an
upperclassman verbally abused as steward
against all tradition he told the jerk
to pick on someone his own size it was a
familiar refrain during just six decades
of service where did such strength of
the conviction come from perhaps from a
family where honor was in the atmosphere
or from the first-hand experience of
cruelty which left physical reminders
that lasted his whole life or from some
deep well of moral principle whatever
the cause it was this combination of
courage and decency that defined at
John's calling and so closely paralleled
the calling of his country this
combination of courage and decency that
makes the American military something
new in history an unrivaled power for
good this combination of courage and
decency that set America on a journey
into the world to liberate death camps
to stand guard against extremism and to
work for the true peace that comes only
with freedom John felt these commitments
in his bones it is a tribute to his
moral compass that dissidents and
prisoners in so many places from Russia
to North Korea to China knew that he was
on their side
and I think their respect meant more to
him than any medals in honours life
could bring the passion for fairness and
justice extended to her own military
when a private was poorly equipped or
seaman was overworked in terrible
conditions John enjoyed nothing more
than dressing down an admiral or a
general he remained the Troublesome
plebe to the end those in political
power were not exempt at various points
throughout his long career John
confronted policies and practices that
he believed were unworthy of his country
to the face of those in authority John
McCain would insist we are better than
this America is better than this John
Izzy the first to tell you was not a
perfect man but he dedicated his life to
national ideals that are as perfect as
men and women have yet conceived he was
motivated by a vision of America carried
ever forward every up ever upward on the
strength of its principles he saw our
country not only as a physical place or
power but as the carrier of enduring
human aspirations as an advocate for the
oppressed as a defender of the peace as
a promise unwavering undimmed unequal
the strength of a democracy is renewed
by reaffirming the principles on which
it was founded in America somehow has
always found leaders who were up to that
task particularly at the time of
greatest need John was born to meet that
kind of challenge to defend and
demonstrate the defining ideals of our
nation if we're ever tempted to forget
who we are to grow weary of our cause
John's voice will always come as a
whisper over our shoulder we are better
than this America is better than this
John was a restless soul he really
didn't glory and success or wallow and
failure
because he was always on to the next
thing friends said he can't stay in the
same experience one of his books ended
with the words and I moved on
John has moved on he would probably not
want us to dwell on it but we are better
for his presence among us the world is
smaller for his departure and we will
remember him as he was unwavering
undimmed unequal
[Applause]
- John's beloved family mrs. McCain -
Cindy and the McCain children president
mrs. Bush president Secretary Clinton
vice president and mrs. Biden vice
president mr. Cheney Vice President Gore
and as John would say my friends we come
to celebrate an extraordinary man a
warrior a statesman a patriot who
embodied so much that is best in America
President Bush and I are among the
fortunate few who competed against John
at the highest levels of politics he
made us better presidents just as he
made the Senate better just as he made
this country better so for someone like
John to ask you while he's still alive
to stand and speak of him when he's gone
is a precious and singular honor now
when John called me with that request
earlier this year
I'll admit sadness and also a certain
surprise but after our conversation
ended I realized how well it captured
some of John's essential qualities to
start with John liked being
unpredictable even Lowell contrary he
had no interest in conforming to some
prepackaged version of what a senator
should be and he didn't want a memorial
that was going to be prepackaged either
it also showed John's disdain for
self-pity
he had been to hell and back and yet
somehow never lost his energy or his
optimism or his zest for life so cancer
did not scare him and he would maintain
that buoyant spirit to the very end too
stubborn to sit still opinionated as
ever fiercely devoted to his friends and
most of all to his family it showed his
irreverence his sense of humor
a little bit of a mischievous streak
after all what better way to get a last
laugh than to make George and I say nice
things about him to a national audience
and most of all it showed a large nassif
spirit an ability to see past
differences in search of common ground
and in fact on the surface John and I
could not have been more different were
of different generations I came from a
broken home and never knew my father
John was the scion of one of America's
most distinguished military families I
have a reputation for keeping cool John
not so much
we were standard bearers of different
American political traditions and
throughout my presidency John never
hesitated to tell me when he thought I
was screwing up which by his calculation
was about once a day but for all our
differences for all the times we sparked
I never tried to hide and I think John
came to understand the long-standing
admiration that I had for him by his own
account John was a rebellious young man
in his case that's understandable what
faster way to distinguish yourself when
you're the son and grandson of admirals
then to mutiny eventually though he
concluded that the only way to really
make his mark on the world
is to commit to something bigger than
yourself and for John dad meant
answering the highest of callings
serving his country in a time of war
others this week
and this morning have spoken to the
depths of his torment and the depths of
his courage there in the cells of Hanoi
when day after day year after year that
youthful iron was tempered into steel
and it brings to mind something that
Hemingway wrote and the book that Megan
referred to his favorite book today is
only one day in all the days that will
ever be but what will happen in all the
other days that ever come can depend on
what you do today in captivity John
learned in ways that few of us ever will
the meaning of those words
now each moment each day each choice is
a test and John McCain passed that test
again and again and again and that's why
when John spoke with virtues like
service and duty it didn't ring hollow
they weren't just words to him it was a
truth that he had lived and for which he
was prepared to die and it forced even
the most cynical to consider what were
we doing for our country what might we
risk everything for now much has been
said
this week about what a maverick John was
now in fact John was a pretty
conservative guy trust me I was on the
receiving end of some of those votes but
he did understand that some principles
transcend politics that some values
transcend party he considered it part of
his duty to uphold those principles and
uphold those values
John cared about the institutions of
self-government our Constitution our
Bill of Rights rule of law separation of
powers even the arcane rules and
procedures of the Senate he knew that in
a nation as big and boisterous and
diverse as ours those institutions those
rules those norms are what bind us
together to give shape and order to our
common life even when we disagree
especially when we disagree
John believed in honest argument and
hearing other views he understood that
if we get in the habit of bending the
truth to suit political expediency or
party orthodoxy our democracy will not
work that's why I was willing to buck
his own party at times occasionally work
across the aisle on campaign finance
reform and immigration reform that's why
he championed a free and independent
press as vital to our democratic debate
and the fact that it earned him some
good coverage didn't hurt either
John understood as JFK understood as
Ronald Reagan understood that part of
what makes our country great is that our
membership is based not on our bloodline
not on what we look like what our last
name SAR it's not based on where our
parents or grandparents came from or how
recently they arrived but on adherence
to a common creed that all of us are
created equal endowed by our creator
with certain inalienable rights it's
been mentioned today and we've seen
footage this week of John pushing back
against supporters who challenged my
patriotism during the 2008 campaign that
was grateful but I wasn't surprised as
Joe Lieberman said it was John's
instinct I never saw John treat anyone
differently because of their race or
religion or gender and I'm certain that
in those moments that have been referred
to during the campaign he saw himself as
defending America's character not just
mine pre considered it the imperative of
every citizen who loves this country to
treat all people fairly and finally
while John and I disagreed on all kinds
of foreign policy issues we stood
together on America's role as the one
indispensable nation believing that with
great power and great blessings comes
great responsibility that burden is
borne most heavily by our men and when
in uniform servicemembers like Doug
Jimmy and Jack who followed their
father's footsteps as well as the
families who serve alongside our troops
but John understood that our security
and our influence was one not just by
our military might not just by our
wealth not just by our ability to bend
others to our will but from our capacity
to inspire others with our adherence to
a set of universal values like rule of
law and human rights and an insistence
on the god-given dignity of every human
being and of course John was the first
to tell us that he was not perfect like
all of us who go into public service he
did have an ego like all of us there was
no doubt some votes he cast some
compromises he struck some decisions he
made that he wish he could have back
it's no secret it's been mentioned that
he had a temper and when it flared up it
was a force of nature a wonder to behold
his jaw grinding his face reddening his
eyes boring a hole right through you not
that I ever experienced it firsthand
mind you
but to know John was to know that as
quick as his passions might flare he was
just as quick to forgive and ask for
forgiveness he knew more than most his
own flaws in his blind spots he knew how
to laugh at himself and that
self-awareness made him all the more
compelling yeah we didn't advertise it
but every so often over the course of my
presidency John would come over to the
White House and we just sit and talk in
the Oval Office just the two of us we
talk about policy and we talk about
family and we talk about the state of
our politics and our disagreements
didn't go away during these private
conversations those were real and they
were often deep but we enjoyed the time
we shared away from the bright lights
and we laughed with each other and we
learned from each other and we never
doubted the other man's sincerity or the
other man's patriotism or that when all
was said and done we were on the same
team we never doubted we were on the
same team for all of our differences we
shared a fidelity to the ideals for
which generations of Americans have
marched and fought and sacrificed and
given their lives we considered our
political battles a privilege an
opportunity to serve as stewards of
those ideals here at home and to do our
best to advance them around the world we
saw this country as a place where
anything is possible
and citizenship citizenship as an
obligation to ensure it forever remains
that way and more than once during his
career John drew comparisons to Teddy
Roosevelt and I'm sure it's been noted
that Roosevelt's man in the arena
oration seems tailored to John most of
you know it Roosevelt speaks and those
who strive who dare to do great things
who sometimes win and sometimes come up
short but always relish a good fight a
contrast to those cold timid souls who
know neither victory nor defeat isn't
that this spirit we celebrate this week
that's striving to be better to do
better to be worthy
of the great inheritance that our
founders bestowed so much of our
politics our public life our public
discourse can seem small and mean and
petty trafficking and bombast and
insulin in phony controversies and
manufactured outrage
it's a politics that pretends to be
brave and tough but in fact is born of
fear
John called on us to be bigger than that
he called on us to be better than that
today is only one day in all the days
that we'll ever be but what will happen
in all the other days that will ever
come can depend on what you do today
what better way to honor John McCain's
life of service then as best we can
follow his example to prove that the
willingness to get in the arena and
fight for this country is not reserved
for the few it is open to all of us that
in fact it's demanded of all of us as
citizens of this great Republic that's
perhaps how we honor investment by
recognizing that there are some things
bigger than party or ambition or money
or fame or power that there are some
things that are worth risking everything
forward principles that are eternal
truth
that are abiding at his best John showed
us what that means for that we are all
deeply in his debt may God bless John
McCain may God bless this country he
served so well
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
let us pray O God of grace and glory we
remember before you this day our brother
John we thank you for giving him to us
his family and friends to know and to
love as a companion on our earthly
pilgrimage in your boundless compassion
console us who mourn give us faith to
see in death the gate of eternal life so
that in quiet confidence we may continue
our course on earth until by your call
we are reunited with those who have gone
before through Jesus Christ our Lord
amen
most merciful God whose wisdom is beyond
our understanding
deal graciously with John's family and
friends in their grief surround them
with your love that they may not be
overwhelmed by their loss
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a reading from the second letter of
Saint Paul to the Corinthians
so we are always confident even though
we know that while we are at home in the
body we are away from the Lord for we
walk by faith not by sight yes we do
have confidence and we would rather be
away from the body and at home with the
Lord the word of the Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a reading from the Gospel according to
Saint John chapter 15 verses 12 through
13 Jesus said this is my commandment
that you love one another as I have
loved you no greater love than this to
lay down one's life for one's friends
the word of the Lord
let us remember john mccain with the
words of the jesuit poet Gerard Manley
Hopkins what I do is me for that I came
but I see more the just man justices
keeps grace that keeps all his goings
Grace's acts in God's eye
what in God's eye he is Christ for
Christ plays in 10,000 places lovely in
limbs lovely and eyes not his to the
Father through the features of men's
faces don't misunderstand me I am not
recommending John for sainthood he was
so very human and for that reason we
can't see God in his life he was the
just man justices for John McCain every
human being deserved to be treated
justly he saw God our Father through the
features of every person especially the
poor and those persecuted by power and
those in need John was a man who loved
and he knew that love is seen in actions
in doing he was so often surrounded by
the servicemen and women
he had such a special affection for we
can hear him in Shakespeare's words but
we we shall be remembered we we few we
happy few we band of brothers
love is truly shown in action and God in
His love has given us this Warrior as a
sign who acted in God's eye
what in God's eye he was though we are
sad we do celebrate the life of our
friend husband father senator and
warrior by because he did keep grace
Christ playing in 10,000 places he gave
us an example of how to live how to be
the just man and with st. Paul John can
now say I have fought the good fight I
have finished the race I have kept the
faith goodbye John McCain
[Music]
[Music]
the pipes are cool
from girl to girl
the mountains
[Music]
it's you it's you
[Music]
but
[Music]
[Music]
Danny Boy
[Music]
and if you come
[Music]
the place
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as Jesus taught us so we now pray our
Father who art in heaven hallowed be thy
name thy kingdom come thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven give us this
day our daily bread and forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but deliver us from evil for
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory forever and ever amen
for our brother John let us pray to our
Lord Jesus Christ who said I am
resurrection and I am life Lord you
consoled Martha and Mary in their
distress draw near to us who mourn her
John and dry the tears of those who weep
eros you wept at the grave of Lazarus
your friend
comfort us in our sorrow
you raise the dead to life give to our
brother eternal life you promised
paradise to the thief who repented bring
our brother to the joys of heaven
comfort us in our sorrows at the death
of our brother let our faith be our
consolation and eternal life our hope
father of all we pray to you for John
and for all those whom we love but see
no longer grant to them eternal rest let
light perpetual shine upon them may his
soul and the souls of all the departed
through the mercy of God rest in peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give rest oh Christ to your servant with
your Saints we're sorry
you only are immortal the creator and
maker of mankind and we are mortal
formed of the earth and to earth shall
we return for so did you ordain when you
created me saying you are dust and to
dust you shall return all of us go down
to the dust yet even at the grave we
make our song aleluia aleluia aleluia
empress
into your hands
Oh merciful Savior we commend your
servant John acknowledge we humbly
beseech you a sheep of your own flock a
lamb of your unfold a sinner of your own
redeeming receive him into the arms of
your mercy into the Blessed rest of
everlasting peace and into the glorious
company of the Saints in light and may
the God of peace who brought again from
the dead our Lord Jesus Christ the Good
Shepherd of the Sheep with the blood of
the everlasting covenant make you
perfect in every good work to do his
will in the days you have and in the
lives to which you have been called
working as he works in you what is
pleasing in his sight and the blessing
of God Almighty the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit be with you and remain
with you now and always
let us go forth in the name of Christ
thanks be to God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]